greetings to podcast ville it's Monday
April 8 the Church of what's happening
now is brought to you by manscaped don't
cut your dick off [ __ ] oh the suffering
ends now with manscape you could get it
done without the pain they got precision
tools for your family jewels manscape
has redesigned the electric razor to
keep your balls your nuts looking
[ __ ] tremendous you understand me so
right now the church family get 20% off
your first order when you use promo code
church at manscape calm and if you order
the perfect package they also throw the
free travel bag which is [ __ ]
tremendous you could put [ __ ] condoms
in there and [ __ ] grease whatever the
[ __ ] else you want to travel with when
you use code church that's manscape com
use promo code church for 20% off your
first order keep your balls clean [ __ ]
up this summer's coming the church is
also brought to you by hims have you
ever looked at a fall over yourself from
five years ago and thought damn I look
too young whatever happens to that guy
whether all the wrinkles come from when
did I start looking like my dad listen
to me
hymns has anti-aging kits a custom
prescription tea cream tailored to your
skin that keep you looking good they got
medication to help you with the little
problem if you go on a date and you want
to have that little um fear and they can
also help you with hair problems you
understand me hymns is a tremendous
company so do me a favor order now and
get $20 off your first month of hymns
anti-aging kit lock-in those looks now
and get your first month i vant the
agent for $20 see website for full
details and safety information go to
hims comm slash Joey s SC that's for
hims comm slash Joey SC for hims com in
fact I'm gonna give him a call myself
I'm getting old as a [ __ ] kick
this [ __ ] mealy what's the story
oh my god pleasure thank you thank you
haven't seen you in a while since at The
Comedy Store I've always been a fan of
yours for many reasons because Richard
prized everything to me I was always
scared of this meeting with you
because I'm gonna cry
now say yeah he was everything to me I
mean he saved me he saved you know when
I heard these albums is a seven-year-old
8 year old nine year old I was blown
away by the language yeah
I'm CUBAN you know they don't let you
say [ __ ] and my mom was very outspoken
you know and Richard was introduced to
be probably I don't know that was about
eight maybe mom and I was obsessed like
and that was it you know in the main
albums were the biggest crazy was it
something I said
Bicentennial early laughs stuff that was
just that was just mind blowing for gala
and yeah I watched the documentary
Mauricio said you would gonna go out and
talk a little bit I really appreciate
you taking the time oh oh I'm happy to
be here first of all without meeting you
I know how tough you are
if I wasn't if I was the situation I
would call you because I know you show
up at [ __ ] back that's right a gallon
of milk and we go back to back with your
comics wife yeah a real comic yeah never
mind Richard Pryor who had major-league
demons yeah I yield the toughest you're
one of the toughest women oh yeah you
know I mean when I watched I am prior
documents but they do I have Richard
private documents when I knew this story
before you left and came back for more
[ __ ] abuse not that he yeah I figured
you were but it was just the ups and
downs of the life of a comic yeah yeah
and most importantly the pain that he
had that what I really noticed in that
documentary yeah that's the first time
that while I watched something Richards
I always cry yeah sometimes I company a
late night I put on an album
Bicentennial [ __ ] and I'll just cry
because it's such a piece of my
childhood and it overtook me from being
a regular Spanish kid to being outspoken
and cursing it
you remember the old Fig Newton
commercial chewy chewy chewy yeah I
would say do we do
joonie on the inside inside all that
[ __ ] came from Richard and like Richard
sparked my said shaking boy did you well
well he sparked your creativity
creativity and your ability to and your
need to express yourself and that's the
beauty of Richard I think Richard you
know change creative culture in that way
it wasn't just comedians who were moved
by him it were it was a lot of people it
was actors and writers and artists and
because he spoke to the humanity in
people and he obviously he touched
something and you very deeply that
allowed you to express yourself stuff
that needed to come out and and you
wanted to come out but there was no way
to to do that and you found the key and
Richard was the key that unlocked that
door I met him in 77 I worked for him
first and you just answered an ad was
that no no no he was a friend of mine
Lucy Saroyan William Saroyan and the
writers daughter she was a good friend
of mine and she was working for him she
was also [ __ ] him and and she was a
consultant on his NBC variety show and
she said he's just what the south in
Northridge we got to fix it up he wants
to decorate it I need help can you help
me and I've been working in Texas I was
on the road with a friend of mine
singing and songwriting and clubs and
stuff and I got back and and and you
know she said you need a gig and I met
him and the first time I met him August
22nd 1977 and I wrote about it I fell
madly in love
I mean his vulnerability and I didn't
know much about his career you know I'd
never seen him doing stand-up he knew we
had this but you know Lucy told me he
had this rep and he you know duh but I I
really was I was captured by the man you
know I just was so touched by him of
course I'd come to work and I come early
to meet the workmen to do the house over
he'd come out every morning with a new
woman and I might oh he's got it going
on you know I didn't care I just wild
horses couldn't drag me away and one
night it was my birthday and he gave me
an envelope of coke and and those were
the days man right and it was good [ __ ]
- or Laurie tell you and and he said you
got to spend the night I'm
not gonna let you drive back you know I
lived in Hollywood at the time and Lucy
came in with you know coke rimmed
nostrils about you know dawn Sun was
coming up she goes we got to get out of
here Richard pulled a gun on me I said
well I gotta be here in an hour anyway
I mean I you know I got to work here so
I I'm not gonna go anywhere well she
never spoke to me again because Richard
came in right after she took off and he
said yeah I pulled the gun on her she uh
you know she wouldn't give me a [ __ ]
I mean what can I tell you I you know I
kind of giggled and and he he said
listen my house is torn up all I've got
can you help can you stay I said oh sure
I'll stay wild horses could not have
dragged me away I was I was there and I
was loyal to him even then we were not
dating
I was just adored him he married Deborah
in the meantime he went through the NBC
variety show Richard's life in one week
is like somebody living in Nebraska for
25 or 30 years
the [ __ ] that would go down in one week
in his life was so fast and furious I
mean you you know you had to hang on for
dear life to keep up right but yeah he
married Debra and then he shot the car
remember that incident he said you're
leaving but the Hush Puppies [ __ ]
you're not in my car bang bang shot the
tires shot the engine and she was in the
car with her girlfriends and I was back
east visiting my family for Christmas
and I came back and was told do not
contact him there's you know he was in
jail I mean there's drama going on he
called me cuz well what the [ __ ] where
are you and again we had not started you
know anything by then and I said well
you know I was told to stay away he said
please come see me and from then on that
was January 78 we were together and that
he was huge in January you just off yeah
yeah but I had never been to the comedy
store so we're day
we go to Hawaii together we come back
and we're out on the town one night and
we're on Coldwater Canyon on the way
back to Northridge he does a Yui and
says I got a surprise we pull into the
Comedy Store
I'd never been in the coma store we walk
in I don't say a word I'm like where are
we going because you'll see he puts me
seat seated next to Mitzi goes up on
stage and starts talking about candle
wax on the floor
that's how no net Richard was he would
work so spontaneously and he would
woodshed he was also so disciplined when
he worked so he started talking about
candle wax on the floor and out of that
he would spin like alchemy this stories
and would just come and then and I would
start taking notes just spontaneously
and every night we go to the store and
he would take a couple of pieces from
the night before expand on them and
woodshed you know the term woodshed and
then the next morning and we'd sit by
the pool and we go over the notes and I
say Richard you got to move more talk
more about women and love women love it
and you know and at the end of six weeks
he had live in concert live in Long
Beach that was the first big one the
first big one okay I mean he had done
live in smokin at the bitter end I mean
The Improv asari The Improv in New York
[ __ ] menu by yes that's a brush
that's the one that sent me yeah top
yeah I started stand-up that's
interesting on that one
and I'll never forget them when this guy
doesn't and the funny thing is you look
at the prices on the menu yeah 25:10
french fries that's the one that [ __ ]
me up it's so interesting to hear saying
that because every comment has their one
for you it was live live in smokin four
summits live in concert four summits
live on Sunset well for me it was as a
commitment I became as a fan it was live
on Sunset as a comedian he taught me
what to do once I watched live and
smoking really once i watch live and
smoke
that one opened my eyes to the non
glamorous side of comedy you always see
curtains and this guy come up and bring
you up
Richard it seemed like Richard just went
up there off the car and somebody was
taping him yeah and it set me [ __ ] on
fire yeah
Michael Blum filmed that I bought that
from him so we own that now too
yeah thank God yeah that's when I came
back I had to start coalescing all
Richard [ __ ] you know his legacy so now
what's going on in January 78 oh well
January 78 so it's rock and roll man I
mean it is you know The Comedy Store
every night he he's you know he realizes
he wants to divest himself of those
demons that made him shoot the car and
that was Rich's genius he turned that
that scene which was could have been
really negative I mean he was arrested
right what was that what was the line he
said and then the cops came and they got
guns too but they don't shoot cars I
went in the house because they don't do
cars they shoot yep yep yep and and you
know he said let's turn this into you
know that was Richard's genius he would
take his anything bad or negative or
painful and which is what comedians do
it was supposed to do right that's what
you're meant to do if you're that honest
right if you can be that raw with
yourself and exposed and then and then
turn that into genius being exposed like
that's really hard to do all the time
this is what I this is how I mean I
understand Richard more and more as I
get older and as I look at him in his
work you're walking a razor wire every
day you know it as yeah and sometimes
you fall off because it's a goddamn
struggle and it doesn't matter it
doesn't make you bad it just makes you
makes you human
you struggle yeah you might do some bad
things yeah he hit me yeah he did drugs
yeah he [ __ ] around where well that
doesn't make him a bad man
Richard happened to be a really good man
he was a wonderful person you know
everyone wants to talk about his genius
and I am more than happy to talk about
it sort but I'm here to tell you all
he was a good person he was generous
give me the shirt off his back help
anybody he could I heard his story once
about Adam Sandler [ __ ] pissed me off
he a homeless guy in a wheelchair was
asking for money he says me and I have
to work for a living - you know what
Richard would have done would have
peeled off a couple of hundreds in a
heartbeat you know that's the kind of
man Richard was even if that guy was
maybe faking it who knows
didn't matter alright so get over on me
who cares
he had such a spirit richard essence was
good he was a sweet guy he was a sweet
guy that vulnerability again that i talk
of you know and the pain that he had
that never left him you know and you
have drugs they were at certain points
they were his comfort they comforted him
right it's like a couple of drinks you
can't drink the bottle but you know you
can have a couple of drinks or a joint
or whatever you do but you can't tip
over and Richard tipped over obviously
he went past that line you know and that
was only he hurt himself more than
anybody any points in his career do you
want to stop stop the coke oh yeah no no
no that was the thing that I was so
impressed with when I watched him
prepare a live in concert he was very
disciplined he would go to the store
every night yeah and then and then the
next day as I said go over the notes and
work on what he was gonna do that night
and the afternoon he would take a nap
and then I'd pick a wonderful piece of
clothing for him to wear you know I
loved dressing him and beautiful clothes
and he would go out and he would do the
same thing again he would you know
woodshed
you know peel away what was it working
ad what was working find new material
and it was amazing I mean he he really
he was very disciplined yeah he was
doing coke coming in a way but he was
not over-the-top who was at the store in
78 when you
oh my god well Robin was there you know
yeah Robin yeah Letterman I mean they
were all there and and you know it was
incredible it everybody was in awe of
Richard I don't care who was there with
Fame Richard was the one who when he got
on stage everybody watched him and
nobody wanted to follow him yeah you
know that could be right yeah yeah but
it was you know and Mitzie of course was
thrilled to pieces and you know what a
character she was yeah what do you think
of her memorial by the way I wanted to
ask you I didn't go
why because Cubans always Cubans are
like [ __ ] Irish yeah I get so
emotional and funerals I start smacking
[ __ ] there was a fistfight my
mother's and then the last memorial at
the store I went there was Marilyn
Martinez and I threatened Jeff Valdez
that night I will smack the [ __ ] up oh
my god I have bad blood with a couple
comics they knew were gonna be up there
yeah Jeff Jeff was there he spoke yeah
yeah I cherish Mitzi Mitzi was like a
mother to me but I knew if I were to go
in there they honest max it was
disappointing yeah and I heard that he
was there and he caused the scene so it
was disappointing I was supposed to
speak on behalf of Richard in the big
room and I was cut out the way a lot of
women were and so what in the o.r and I
said to whose dices girlfriend you know
she kind of runs the show over there oh
yeah yeah yeah
I said no wonder let me get up and say
some [ __ ] because this is Richie's
favorite room anyway that was that was
the room he adored so I said let me say
some [ __ ] well you know after she let 89
people ahead of me I'm for course you
know I got on and there were three
people left in the audience which you
know I kind of felt insulted on behalf
of Richard and Mitzi because they had a
serious bond
I recently well not recently but I found
out that that they had [ __ ] and which
was very interesting to me
would you [ __ ] everybody yeah he did
about you is that you knew it
and you like you accepted it you said
there's nothing I'm gonna do with this
[ __ ] animal he's an animal he's a
[ __ ] that way you know when he gets
off stage yeah and he does what he does
he's gonna [ __ ] he's gonna snort that's
what's gonna keep him there that's right
that's what's gonna keep him there yeah
for me I was not a good looking guy so I
couldn't [ __ ] a lot of people but for
him that's we was and you accepted the
documentary you've spoken about yeah for
years like yeah that's because you loved
him and I knew he loved me
yeah yeah I know he loved me he called
me one night from hookers house and said
Jennifer I'm here with this woman I'm
telling her how much you mean to me how
much you love me baby I said can you
come here and tell me you know but you
know I knew it was it was part of him
that he probably would never you know
forgo he would never give that up and
did it hurt me sure it hurt me but it
never definitely to me what it was just
say you know I get it you know it was it
but I knew he loved me you know and I'd
been around the block some you know I've
been with some interesting guys right
but I never felt loved she was a nice
dude warm baby Oh Warren was a good
reason he was a director yeah it was on
last night and I saw the movie the last
one he did that he directed about Howard
Hughes Howard use yes I was one of the
gang guys that was supposed to throw him
out of the hotel and [ __ ] yeah but he
talked to me was a gentleman yeah I was
in awe like this is shampoo yeah like
explain the people who the [ __ ] Warren
Beatty was in 1970 they don't know he
was the man he was slinging more dictum
dictum Richard he was he really he did
that's a it's they were friends you know
Oh Richard was friends with every they
all yeah I think Richard drew people to
him you made a comment a couple months
ago that destroyed me aliens not it
didn't destroy me but I liked that week
two articles that come on about it
Oh Brando about Brando oh yeah yeah yeah
how did you guys meet Brando oh well oh
well you know actually the truth is that
I just found out from a friend of mine
where
they met and it was at Reds club on La
Brea before I knew Richard because
people are saying how do you know that
for a fact
well I wasn't there so I don't know it
for a fact but I can tell you this much
if Quincy says it because Quincy doesn't
pour the tea like that you know and what
Q is taking so much [ __ ] for that I mean
he still is taking [ __ ] for it for
saying that you know time that Marvin
Gaye and listen you know Richard love
[ __ ] there's no question about it he
wasn't gay
hey you know sometimes a mouth as a
mouth as a mouth what are you gonna you
know I'm when you get wait listen what I
said was it was the 70s when you smart
enough cocaine you [ __ ] radiators and
that was the wrong you know but rich you
didn't have a lot of shame about it and
I think that came from his childhood you
know when when he saw everything was
allowed right everything went on in that
whorehouse right
he was also molested as a kid and that's
like another whole other topic but you
know Richard didn't carry a lot of shame
about it I mean look what he said him to
the Hollywood Bowl oh [ __ ] yeah he had
told me about that a couple years ago
and then I saw it in the documentary
before yeah but you [ __ ] aren't
nothing like you where were you yeah
where were you when Watts was burning
you know he was pissed off and there a
couple of different stories about it but
the one he told me was he saw the the
Locker group the dance group the lockers
being mistreated with some bigotry and
racism on in the dressing rooms and it
really pissed him off and it was
supposed to be it was hey it was titled
human evening of human rights and he
realized that oh no this is all about
gay rights so what's going on here and
they're mistreating some black people
here and he really got pissed off and he
just let him have it you know I mean
that's Richard that's vintage Richard
vintage Richard that's are you supposed
to you know that's what you're supposed
to do tell the truth so I stuck some
disks what's the big deal you know I
mean god bless him you know I loved out
of this document there what I really
loved to buy and Richard that
they should rich is starting off and
kind of navigating to the Cosby thing
that's a man I can't [ __ ] stand yeah
I never [ __ ] standing then I can't
stand them I like the one arm because he
talked about buck buck and we played one
[ __ ] as a kid New York City I'm from
Yuba that's a game that you stand on the
wall and then there would be hosed their
waists and you go with your ass out and
then so there's five people and then
five people have to jump on the human
chain and break it so you pick the
weakest person who's the weakest person
you get on top then you jump on top of
me and then we start beating that person
or if it's a bulldog Ouiser tits you
know
oh god chain breaks then you do it again
and we played hot peas and brother go
get your mother you gotta hide a belt
and then you're walking on my god yeah
hi yeah I took these kids down the
corner and you get the belt you get to
whip them all the way the place it's a
metal belt oh yeah we got down announcer
in the early 70s so that's the only
reason why I like Azmi but I really I
think that that part really was for
comedians to know that yeah you play the
game the first six or seven years
accommodating you play the game you play
this [ __ ] stupid safe game that's
what especially when you come here yep
these [ __ ] agents tell you well you
have to go up there and paint a picture
of your sitcom so like when myspace came
up you know my yeah action was in my
space I'm like I wonder if Richard Pryor
was alive alive would he go home and get
on MySpace no no he'd be snorting coke
and getting his dick sucked so I'm not
getting on MySpace either but then
social media took over and you had to
but I liked the part that one day he
said [ __ ] all this yeah [ __ ] all this
nice guy with a suit and a tie
yeah you know trying to be [ __ ]
Martin Luther King jr. up on stage I'm
gonna [ __ ] and go for it yeah and he
started talking about drugs and the y
know that y know meets Dracula yeah that
subunits like well that that's a pivotal
point when he goes to Berkeley he walks
off right in Vegas right and that is
that's why I love the documentary talk
about that too
it really shows his evolution as an
artist his growth and and how he became
Richard Pryor I am Richard Pryor that is
we all want to know where was it what
was the key and the key was Berkeley it
was the first time he was hanging out
with smart black [ __ ] - I mean
Ishmael Reed and Cecil brown and the
Panthers he saw that there was something
else besides this you know this the
one-trick pony the jokes and the the
[ __ ] that Vegas and he was making a
nice living so for this young kid to
finally kind of you know following in
Cosby's by the way I agree about cause
we can't stand up and what I say about
Cosby is clean on the outside dirty on
the inside and Richard dirty on the
outside green on the inside yeah and
that's the difference Oreo cookie - I
mean come on you know he's really you
know does it not it not a truth-teller
that man I didn't like that years later
when I got into comedy he did something
Colorado and I was in the room I walked
in and I was unsure if I wasn't a say
anything to him and he started talking
about dirty comics how they're not
really Camille oh god he's on that kick
meanwhile he's don't some women with
[ __ ] quaaludes meanwhile in 87 one of
the girls from the show Lisa Bonet did a
sex scene with Mickey Rourke and she had
him five he had a five from the NBC show
this is to let you know the [ __ ] in the
hypocrisy [ __ ] Cosby was all when we
went down to see him that was kind of
pissed ugly like don't give that [ __ ]
this before the rape allegation yeah
Peter we paid a yardstick I'm with the
San Diego mime we don't go see that yeah
yeah he's an embarrassment the [ __ ]
time well he started lecturing everybody
you know Ebonics why is everyone talking
talk real English I mean in Hannibal
Buress he was the one that brother was
the one who finally just said why are we
listening to him he's a rapist band that
caught fire didn't it that little shitty
gorilla video that somebody took grainy
fucked-up video that just caught fire
the poor guy I think it I think it
marked him to do you know what I mean I
think he got love hate for that I think
a lot in the black community no matter
no matter they can see some it's like
what Trump says I can kill somebody on
Fifth Avenue his base wouldn't give a
[ __ ]
thing about Cosby and sometimes
african-americans look at look at
Jackson right I shouldn't go down this
road I know oh yeah we do I mean you
know it's just sorry guys but right is
right and truth is truth and wrong is
wrong so you know if somebody's wrong
and they get called out they got to deal
with it they got to deal with the truth
and boy I tell you that Cosby he's doing
a hard time Jennifer did you smell his
pain Richards
oh god you know it Oh still I still do I
still do I you know he just went through
so much he suffered that's why I just I
was so in love with him I mean he's just
he wore at all it was right there for
you to see and the way he would connect
with everybody I mean the rednecks I
Richard Pryor you really you know I mean
people didn't like black people KKK
listen to Richard Pryor that's right
they would listen to Richard Pryor
that's exactly what you Pryor was the
one know what killed me though back to
pain like I saw my mother my mother had
this my mother had to leave her daughter
in Cuba my sister and my brother would
be Richard Pryor all day suck my dick
let's do a blast let's do this but about
2:00 a.m. that's when they couldn't fake
the funk no more natural Richard pulled
out the guns to 3:00 a.m. that moment
when you got up to go to the bathroom
mm-hm that pain would show up you'd come
out and see I still haven't yes but that
pain is what drives a great comic yeah
the more the pain the better the [ __ ]
comic and if they touch on it I can I
Drive to the economy story tonight
I don't put musically mm-hmm I go into
my thoughts and I go in the painful
moments for myself you know my father
dying I'm finding my mother on the floor
you know the first time a girl told you
she cheated on yet you dip into those
places truth things that really you know
that think truths that you find that
about yourself they're not all that pain
is what makes me be go up on stage and
be a
[ __ ] animal that's good like I but I
got that and I noticed in all the
documentaries I've watched Richard war
has [ __ ] pain on his sleeve yeah
Richard's pain was right there and I
think I'd do the same at times like I
feel it
I dated my wife for about a year and a
half
can I tell you that I thought she was
okay I liked her a lot
Bluto my wife is naive as can be she's
from Tennessee mm-hmm she's Irish and
she figured me out well she said
something to me lovely I never said she
said I could tell that you were raised
without a mother
Hey I didn't know what I want to kick
her in the stomach or kiss her mmm but
that opened up my that just made me a
good comic when she said that to me I
had had 2,000 friends that never brought
that up and I always saw that with
Richard like in his movies that those
little pauses and there's a video of him
that he's coked out to the gills Oh
doing an interview Hey yeah I have those
moments of manic yeah where you can't
control what comes out of my mouth yes
the pain is too much yeah I really don't
give a [ __ ] it's like the Mary went to
the Hollywood Bowl yeah he didn't give a
[ __ ] I don't care about the consequences
now and that's what economic does yeah
we do what we do and there's no
consequences
yeah there's no consequence yeah we just
did it now what [ __ ] yeah make the next
move what's your move you got no move
then I'm going to keep doing it yeah
that's it that's what was interesting
about Richard that I really always loved
even when he did that we were talking
about that thing with the lighter yeah
why about the sunset yeah no you
[ __ ] this a theater I asked
remember that but no movie theater died
yeah he threw the [ __ ] up he just turned
stand-up around yes did something that
was he did he did to me Freddie Prinze I
never met him he was gone already
yeah yeah he was gone what year did he
die
there were Richards guns terrified me I
mean I didn't like guns around but
Richard had guns
he died in 77 seven
have guns keep them accessed Richard
pulled a gun on me yeah yeah that's why
I would love no yeah [ __ ] happens man
waste yes I will pull it out yeah my
mistake my mistake
yes yeah it's the schedules not on time
yeah you know it's about the smallest
thing yeah it's not Richard got manic
about the smaller thing yeah yes it's
not the big thing now Bali yeah it's a
small thing yeah that's when you look
over in the white hole crazy over this
you could pop on a pop on a bubble about
that's our mentality yeah that's our
little comedian
we have flaws yeah yeah musicians have
flaws we all have little flaws Richard
brought them up Richard wasn't scared of
exposing no no the more flaws the better
when did you meet Paul Mooney
shortly after I mean I met Paul when I
was in that period of time when I was
working for Richard he would come out to
the house you know he was always you
know [ __ ]
you know Paul was you know Paul was Paul
I told you before I had a love/hate
thing with Paul you know cuz I I saw
sometimes how he well let me tell you
the last time I saw Paul we he was being
Richard was being honored at the writer
at the Directors Guild and he's in a
wheelchair and Paul came in and was was
unkind to Richard I'll just say that and
didn't come to his funeral
the love/hate thing I think was always
somehow in balance but at some points it
went out of balance and Paul would
become very jealous of Richard and
bitter I mean you know his comedy his he
was you know he cleared the room I mean
Mitzi had to blackball him from the
store how many times oh my god at least
20 times you know and then she'd let him
back in because he could empty a room I
mean not to say that some of his stuff
wasn't great it was but he you know he
was he would pick at you he would pick
that you yeah you picked a I mean
that was his genius though that was his
other genes yeah that he would not not
pick on you he would try he would push
the line yeah
well the race thing would really go
after you for the race thing you know
and you know and and it was sometimes
just out of balance and out of whack it
I mean you got it you got a laugh with
it too man you know that's what Richard
was great at he pulled the covers of
black people same as white people you
know and and he made you laugh at it too
yes there was some angry stand-up
routines angry comedic routines Richard
did regarding race but my god it was it
was that stuff was insightful you know I
you know I I just wasn't a Paul Mooney
fan you know I wasn't because I cause I
want Richard too much and I David banks
on the other hand I love David banks I
love David David no David banks said the
funniest [ __ ] thing he's a funny
[ __ ] up at the store he would
have the cocktail David banks was
supposedly Richard manager correct yeah
at one point yeah yeah David banks
started coming around the store when I
was a regular well he was he had been
going up there and I went to the store
one night and he's got there with that
little glass he would have that little
glass of whatever the [ __ ] he drank with
his ice cubes right and he would jiggle
the [ __ ] glasses I'm gonna met
Arsenio Paul Eddie Murphy and Johnny
Gill you're at the store by the light by
the comedy store lane me and David banks
go and Arsenio I think I just had
certainly already Paul David banks goes
Cuba watch this he walked over to me
goes so one of you [ __ ] doing the
Queens account he took the [ __ ] hit
the nail on the head
there was so many things I laughed at
with David banks and Paul moody I
remember one night some white dude
pulled up behind with a convertible and
music really laughs and when he stopped
the car poem when he looked at me goes
what a [ __ ] shame with these white
[ __ ] Negros turned around and
walked in that was [ __ ] by that
before but Richard that documentary
that's what I stuck out the most of was
how much you loved them uh and I know
what it takes to really love a comic
yeah my wife I met my wife and we were
like kind of off and I tried I tried
that calmly suck my dick routine and she
didn't play for it and then I had a
caller and take her on a date
yeah and I didn't have enough money to
take her on a date and I called her up
one day like an 11 and woke her up and I
said I'm coming over to eat and she made
like [ __ ] corn dogs with red beans
and I'm like what the [ __ ] is this but I
was so hungry I'm starving
Tomic I had to eat it but that's what
made me fall in love with mm-hmm she out
of all the women I was dating at the
time she always yeah yeah she kind of
just had the same thing you had for
Richie yeah and I could see in your eyes
when I mean you [ __ ] Scott clear and
you came back for more I did yeah twice
right yeah well yeah I got a little
battle pretty pasty yeah I well you know
Richard recycled women right so after we
divorced in 82 I moved back to New York
and we stayed in touch the whole time
you know we would I'd see him when he
came to New York wasn't he tracked me
down in Paris one time and and said I
got to see you please and I flew to LA
and he picked me up and he had little
booties hanging from the mirror I said
what the [ __ ] of those Richard and he
said oh I just got this girl pregnant
and I knew Richard I oh [ __ ]
you asked me to come back from Paris so
that you could flaunt these little
booties of what the hell and of course
that was flynn and he married her he
actually married her twice too
but when people want to know which wife
I am I say the best one Oh
the first that first date was actually
before he shot the car when I was
working for him he said by the way I've
got to go to this thing with a United
Nations event would you like to go with
me and it was a Beverly at the Beverly
Wilshire and not the Beverly was should
have built Beverly Hilton and I went on
the date with him and David Franklin his
manager inland and he was [ __ ] Lynette
McKay at the time so the four of us had
a double date and on the way home it was
very nice it was very polite stuffy
dinner and on the way home Lynette McKee
started making white jokes and that you
know I I couldn't believe it I mean the
tension the tension was so thick in the
car and he walked me to my house and he
apologized he said I am so sorry Phil
Annette McKay making those jokes and I
said it's okay Richard don't worry about
it
talking about a my first date with
Richard and and it was very sweet it was
like a real date you know he picked me
up and dropped me off and and had to
apologize for Lynette Mikey's racist
comments and he was just he was just a
sweet [ __ ] you know and as I
said I've been around the block and I
just you know basically I felt kind of
tired of it all I'm like I wanted love I
was looking for love and I found it in
Richard and what I found about myself
when I came back I mean first of all the
80s we were back and forth a lot right
and then in 89 he did some see no evil
in New York and I worked with him on
that and I said to him Richard why you
looking like an old man then that's when
he told me he was diagnosed with MS at
any rate in 94 he was in New York doing
a something at the Apollo I went up to
see him at the Helmsley Palace and he
was drinking you know water glasses full
of vodka and pills lined up and I said
Richard you're gonna die
he said I'm in trouble and Deborah was
in the room that that wife from before
and she wanted me to go downstairs and
get the the white lady price for a
diamond ring that was Debra she was all
about her jewelry and I went down stairs
and got the white lady price and Richard
bought her this ring and I'm looking at
this scene thinking you can't make this
up but you know he's drinking and
pilling and everyone's the locus had
descended right and he's a Jenny I'm in
trouble
I'm in trouble I need help would you
come back I said whoa I got to think
about this this is the summer of 94
actually is spring of 94 and I took a
couple trips back and forth I talked to
my father who was an attorney dad's gone
now but brilliant attorney loved Richard
by the way kind of cut out of the same
piece of cloth and I thought long and
hard about it because you know was not
never gonna be easy with Richard but
when I came out and I saw more of what
was going on in that hotel room at his
house he wasn't eating he was on an IV
in his bedroom and there was a cook
cooking three tiered cakes and everybody
walk it out with the food and [ __ ]
counting money like it was Vegas I'm
thinking what the [ __ ] is this and I
realized I had to come back I loved him
and I couldn't watch this I found out
about my own profound sense of loyalty
besides the fact that I never stopped
loving him I what couldn't let him go
down like this and he had guns hidden
everywhere there were guns under
sweaters in his closet guns under the
bathroom sink guns under his pillow I
mean [ __ ] brand-new Berettas in the
box and [ __ ] I don't know anything about
guns except I hate him right
like what the [ __ ] are these guns that I
knew that Richard intended to go through
all his money with all these horrible
people just going through it
then he would go to kill himself I knew
that and I said not on my watch I'm
coming back Richard I am coming back and
I came back in the summer of 94 a couple
months after I had made this decision
and it was such such chaos and it was
just 2 years of putting things in order
and one of the first things I did was
take all those [ __ ] guns and that
[ __ ] ammunition took that ammo down a
Ralph's one morning put it in the
dumpster at 4:00 in the morning one of
his bodyguards said that was good ammo
why did you do that but what good ammo
excuse me what does that mean so I took
all the guns which by the way we're all
in their box brand-new I mean every kind
of gun and I went down on the BB gun
shop it's no longer but in the valley I
sold my house back of my car guy said
you can't sell him in the shop you can
sell him out of your car lady so I went
and I sold him I did a transfer is
legally but um I got rid of those
[ __ ] guns because I knew what was
planned was the gun because of the
cocaine paranoia I think just a national
think it was kind of a natural you know
an embedded paranoia that he had I think
it was a macho thing I also think he had
plans for those guns I know he did so I
came back and I fought like hell you
know I got rid of all the riffraff I
lowered the child support payments
that's why they all came at me you know
Flynn had a trip for 20 people planned
first-class to Maui cancelled Deborah
had a condo where she was going to buy
for her 325,000 canceled you know
Richard needed his money to live right
so I closed the bank of Pryor and let me
tell you something that I'm so proud of
that because you know it took some balls
let me tell you I got threatened by the
housekeeper I know people who can have
you killed she said I said I bet you do
[ __ ]
nine-one-one oh yeah I mean I had a
restraining order on some of those
people one of the wives I won't say who
I mean it was rock and roll
how many people were out with the hands
out oh oh and he was such a good guy
giveth thee easy-peasy peter bogdanovich
the director I found a alone a piece of
paper I just called him up I said you
all Richard some money you pay up Johnny
Gill money but they all had their hands
up and Richard was sick and he was like
and people who were smarter than me
supposed to be watching the forum or not
I'm talking business managers I'm
talking lawyers they were stealing - I
fired all of them the business managers
might he'd begged me said fire that
business manager he's stealing from me
and and the lawyers who had him you know
sixty-five thousand dollar retainer a
month for what he's not working anymore
like that yeah
what the [ __ ] is this money just
hemorrhaging you know my father helped
me navigate a lot of that too I had to
get lawyers and and new people on board
but that's when all the wives and
children went crazy too because I closed
that Bank like BAM boom bank closed
finished the money's for Richard to live
[ __ ] and I knew the plan was
Richard was going to run out of money
and then he was going to off himself not
on my watch
and he lived eleven and a half more
years in dignity and love no but I got
into comedy it was to live like Richard
ha ha it was to live like Richard huh
you know I wanted to get off the coke in
2001 and it took me six years because I
was scared that I would lose the funny
yeah I was scared that I would lose my
craziness I was scared little of that
age yeah that edge I was scared of so
many things but when I just couldn't
carry that yeah you know I've read
Richards books I've read you know
Hollywood Henderson yeah unbelievable
story though he won the lottery twice
that [ __ ]
I just I'm still friends with Connie
Nelson and she hangs with him and she's
a Jennifer he's he's turned out to be
the nicest guy cuz Richard used to run
we used to hang with him yeah twice he
said that is one of his books he said
that he would go and pick the pointer
sisters yeah and Richard up at the
colonies
yeah and they would freebase for [ __ ]
days I mean they were the kings of the
freebase but I also heard an interest a
really wid thing I want you to clarify
me I don't know if you were around you
were Belushi yeah they said that DeNiro
and Robin yeah went to the store true to
pick up Richard Richard had left already
yeah so they walked over the show Oh God
Richard wasn't there Richard was not at
the Chateau no no thank God no that was
that was Robin's and dinero's thing yeah
I was horrible
that was horrible that was really awful
we all heard about that we all heard
that teeth very quickly and in real time
didn't we I mean that [ __ ] spread like
wildfire what's that this truth about
Belushi and how he died and that Cathy
girl that the dealer so it was when you
met Richard Richard was not freebasing
yet
no no oh that started welling in the 80s
that started the fire was June 9 1980
okay the faucet was already free but no
he yeah he started that when he was
working on right before stir crazy he
started that and I came into the house
one day and I'm like what's what's that
smell he the first time he did freebase
he lit the mattress on fire I mean you
know Richard was an arsonist from back
in the day I loved it he started fires
when he was a kid I mean that you know
but I said Richard went and we dragged
the mattress into the bathtub
you know it was but he that [ __ ] and I
did that with him for about ten days and
I'm like I'm out I can't you know that
[ __ ] I could snore it and that was and I
could keep that under control this [ __ ]
was like what kind of high is this it's
like someone took a mallet and goes
whack you're not you're you're just non
compos mentis you're not thinking you're
not aware I said I got to get out of
here Richard and anyway I wrote a poem
to Richard I said Richard this is not
working
said the way you made love to me was a
shame and a disgrace your ice cold heart
chilled my soul your woman is freebase
freebase had moved in
that was the woman it was it took my
place which broke my heart and I got out
he said take all that jewelry off [ __ ]
on your way out what did you leave the
first time well you know there were a
couple of incidents that I you know I'd
go away for a few days and I'd always
come back but this was the biggest thing
I had to go and I asked Jim Brown for
help and you know Jim kept giving me lip
service and no it's okay just you know
go away and I came out the producer of
stir crazy called me and said Richard
has to shoot some pickups they were back
in town from Tucson oh my god the city
the scenes in Tucson with the feds Oh
Lord but we're back in town he had do
some pickups and he refused to do him
because somebody had thrown a watermelon
a member of the crew and Richard it was
a real racist thing to do so Richard was
furious so I went out to the house and
there was a mound of cocaine on this
antique child's desk and they got I
wasn't doing anything at the time
because if I had I would have said [ __ ]
you Richard and I would be dead I woke
up in the morning I stayed the night I
woke up and he was blowing through that
pile going through that was smoking
going through the pile and I said I got
to get out of here he said nope and he
grabbed me by the throat and he was
gonna strangle me somehow I got free I
sat next to him and I just talked him
down he said you're gonna die this
morning and I had a cross around my neck
and I held the cross and I looked out
failed Catholic than I am and I said God
give me the words and I said Richard
just calm down she was like Lauren order
you know when they calm person down just
give me the gun it's okay calm down
everything's gonna be okay and he calmed
down and I made a beeline from my blue
corduroy pants I picked them up and I
left went to the kitchen and Richard
said can you bring me some ox tails and
beans I did I went into the kitchen got
some ox tails and beans that one of his
aunt's was cooking and brought him back
but the next time I came back to the
house was when he set himself on fire
and he said it's gonna happen he said
you need to leave because it's going to
happen to you too and
Richard never made an idle threat never
and I thought okay you know so I went to
the kitchen and there was a bodyguard
there and a couple of you know a couple
hangers on and aunt or two and I said
Richard's gonna hurt himself and they
get out of here create a little crazy
white girl you don't get out by the time
I got back to him I had an apartment I
had taken in Beverly Hills I called the
house I called Jim I said Jimmy's gonna
do some pee pee poo pooed me dismissed
me call the house and Auntie answered
and said what and I said I'm just
checking and all of a sudden she's
screaming Richards then running through
the house on fire the phone drops yeah
I made a beeline for the hospital
Hollywood Presbyterian he went to first
and I talked the doctors and I said he's
loaded on coke and and he's just vodka
and freebase don't kill him you know
don't overdose him with morphine and
that the family was there furious with
me because I was telling them the truth
and then he was moved to the Burn Center
and then you know the rest is history I
mean it goes on from there
yeah he lit himself on fire he poured
that hundred and ninety proof rum over
himself and torched himself he saw that
he said there's no way out from me I did
[ __ ]
chocolate chip cookie yeah that's the
company yeah you know that's the common
that's my [ __ ] no he'll let you have it
if any [ __ ] they feel a little bit yeah
let me tell you really yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I was great when I dip the
chocolate milk yeah yeah that's yeah I
was I was a young kid and I was just
destroyed yeah like this guy I love yeah
he's doing what they were doing at my
house Richard Pryor was doing except
Weber was in freebase she died 279 thank
God she never got to that freebase a
point but she was thought she had a bar
she was cube
she was an alpha woman right she beat up
the husband the step stepfather
Wow threw a cigarette I would not he
waited till she went to sleep he went to
sleep
she took a Catholic figure broke it over
his [ __ ] head and that mother [ __ ]
had a piece of his skin hanging off oh
she would whoop it you know well it's
worse than Irish will grow and the next
day usually with a bad leaves your house
right they leave [ __ ] just to come back
to baby yeah he took everything yeah I
forgot my towel never came back
so I'm done what Richard lit himself oh
I didn't know what to do people were
making fun of me like your hero lit
himself on fire and I didn't know what
to say it was like I just didn't know
what to say yeah
and then that I think it was Sunset
Strip yeah you came back came back was
straight he came back what people don't
know about that is it we shot it in two
nights right the first night he had a
bag toothpicks first night what so you
do know walked offstage yeah and the
second night he killed it but they did
have to do some pickups on that you know
race dark produced it and he wanted some
pickups on that and yeah so and but it
was good I mean he he came clean again
you know talked all about it yeah red
[ __ ] suit with the red suit yeah
would the red suit friend of mine
designed that yeah well that was tabled
Bateson yeah yeah yeah yeah custom-made
Oh wasn't he yeah yeah and like was
there anybody black at the time that did
not otherwise Richard Oh God
Jim Brown you just drop some babes we're
talking yeah yeah the penises yes yeah
it's just endless well you know when he
took me over to Sammy's for the first
time I mean the way Sammy looked at him
too and Sammy was older than him right
so it was kind of a little father thing
going on there but with such love with
such adoration and and amazement too at
the same time you know kind of because
Richard was Richard was doing things
that nobody else was doing really you
no but Sammy was Sammy loved him too I
mean Sammy was you know Sammy was a was
somebody who was always there for him
yeah so you leave you clean now at the
time with you how long were you guys
separated well basically we were
separated by a we divorced in 82 and I
came back in 94 but I you know as I said
we were back and forth a lot you know
he'd come to New York and call me and
you know I you know we we've never
really stopped seeing each other stop
loving each other I mean I went on I had
other boyfriends I tried to have a life
without him but noting everybody paled
in comparison I mean you know nobody
could follow Richard onstage or off you
know nobody and I just yeah I couldn't
shake him I just was madly in love with
that man you know and I miss him to this
day I talked to him I'm like you know
sometimes I'm pissed off like you're
supposed to be here [ __ ] where
are you
sometimes he visits me and I feel his
presence a lot you ever smell oh I do I
smell her that was not bad yeah why do
you remind you your dad you said your
dad oh my oh my well my father 100%
Irish brilliant brilliant lawyer civil
rights attorney rocontour is great
[ __ ] sense of humor womanizer could
polish a bottle of whiskey very similar
man you know and my father you know my
father had his own demons you know he
slugged my mother a few times and my
mother had mental illness and that's the
whole of this story but they eventually
divorced but but I love my dad and I
think I learned from my father that bad
you can do bad things but that doesn't
make you a bad man my father happened to
be a great man I I worship him to this
day he did great things for a lot of
people did he slug my mother yeah was
was was he a prick sometimes aha
but he was a good man and and that's
what I appreciate most is you know
people get confused well he hit you so
he was a bad guy no no sorry
well he did
drugs mmm sorry no no Richard wasn't a
hypocrite
Richard was honest but Richard was a
good person so these these flaws don't
make a person a bad person make they
just doesn't it doesn't
III didn't know much about Richard but
the thing that that struck me then was
he happy well you did like the
documentary just a lot of sadness came
through and I did it it makes me sad
that there's someone who's so funny
would be so sad well I think that don't
you're sitting next to somebody who can
talk to that too I mean there's not
nothing fixes them nothing fixes them I
can tell you that on stage is where
Richard was like gills on a fish he
lived I mean he came alive he was
offstage he had a hard time knowing how
to live life that's real happiness I
think was very elusive I think there
were moments of joy did he understand
the biggest question for me was did he
understand how loved he was that's the
big question
did he ever feel loved you know I know
he felt loved by me but by the masses by
his fans did he ever feel the impact
that he had and I think that as he sat
in the wheelchair as he got older and
this disease took more hold of him the
disease of MS I think that Richard
really came to peace came to acquire a
sense of peace about his life and about
being appreciated and being loved I
think that that maybe was one positive
thing about that damn disease was that
it gave him he didn't have a choice he
was sitting in that damn wheelchair and
he had to face himself he couldn't run
away anymore he couldn't run to the drug
to the whiskey to the [ __ ] he couldn't
run anyway aware Oh any more away from
it he had to face so one of the things I
think he had to face
was that he was loved but I think he did
acquire a sense of peace about his life
I'm 56 years old and I think for three
years I finally been comfortable living
in my skin that's what I'm talking about
my daughter that little girl has really
played a big part in me being
comfortable in my skin mm-hmm
you know when I was hooked on the coke
you know I was booking movies I was
booking I was at admit you would give me
spots four nights a week but then it
that nothing to do once you get
unfounded make a left
to go home yeah reality sets oh yeah
you're a [ __ ] loser your mother did
drugs you know your father did drugs you
went to prison here you got a GED you
know all those things come to light
that's right never mind would just
happen on the stage never mind
you just ripped that [ __ ] original
room to shreds that's right all those
things come back you know and you have
to put them into place that's right for
years I used the drugs to put them into
place you know yeah it's just you know I
tell people when I was doing coke
I would go to pee and I refused to look
in the mirror yeah I would not look at
myself in the mirror I had a walk
through the bathroom I wouldn't look at
a mirror because you don't want to see
yourself yeah somewhere along the way
there's a comet and it made me stronger
mm-hmm getting off the coat dealing with
that [ __ ] dealing with I tell people all
the time
you got skeletons you got a deal you
have let him out from the time the time
yeah how do I let him on that stage yeah
dude we should go to a psychiatrist ever
he was mandated to by the legal system
after shooting the car dr. cannon who
since passed away I didn't like dr.
cannon much because they took advantage
of Richard Richard started giving him
money for this charity or that charity
and then the okie-doke sets in right so
no real work is getting done I go to
therapy and it's it's I love it because
it's a support system you get to look at
issues in your life in your work you get
to learn how to navigate them better you
just get it you know for me it's really
a
Orton to have therapy and I know what
therapy what it takes it takes honesty
and it takes a degree of courage and I
think that Richard just started to buy
the shrink and the shrink went through
you know it got all [ __ ] up but his
psychiatry was the stage I'm sorry
his psychiatrist was the stage sometimes
right oh I'm sorry oh absolutely oh
that's why I don't go away
I want that stay after now this point in
my life I want to go up there and get it
all out I say everything I don't give a
[ __ ] no more I was looking for a job
when I found this when I was 40 I had to
be careful what I said not anymore
okay I'm gonna retire you know I'm going
out with this [ __ ] I don't give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] that's good and I'm
from the school of Richard Pryor yeah
that stage that's good to hear
is your psyche I you know listen I'm a
fan of Kennison I'm a fan of Bill Hicks
yeah you know I love Andrew you know
there's a lot of comedians I love but
nobody's set the tones of me like
Richard yeah like I'm not trying to
emulate Richard I have the same page
oh I didn't see then Richard has and
that makes me a comic yeah like that
pain getting in touch with it you live
your life going for four years it's
right you don't know what the [ __ ] is
bothering you Richard saw a lot of
things that a lot of seven year olds
shouldn't say should say yeah a lot of
eight year olds shouldn't see that when
you're eight nine your world should be
Universal City
yeah you know Donald Duck you should be
protected not being outside getting guys
to come into your grandmother's think
you know why his mom was hooking his
grandmother raised him he had the
support system I think it was his
grandma that really oh oh that's a
double-edged sword a double-edged sword
of allege she she was a nurturer but at
the same time she had a grip that was
iron it was an iron grip was Marie Marie
Carter you better oh yeah I met her me
there's a snake Oh mean it's a
rattlesnake but I understood her you
know she listened she grew up during the
Jim Crow era come on she's not she
wanted Richard to marry um oh come on
the black actress Thank You Pam Grier
every Richard would
he had a golden [ __ ] really Richard I
don't need to hear that she had the best
[ __ ] ever of like okay and me angel
[ __ ] over here please
no he she wanted him to marry Pam Grier
and she called me the Bigfoot
[ __ ] because I wear cowboy boots
in the house and she hear me she you
know I get it I mean she was so damn it
she sent a maid in once with a 2x4 over
my legs smashed it over my legs and
[ __ ] got on top of me and started
strangling me housekeeper she felt I
disrespected her who is this [ __ ]
housekeeper she threatened you well this
is this is this is another housekeeper
this this housekeeper was somebody who
worked for John Schlesinger I was
friends with them John and Michael and
anyway I had her in the house and and
when the grandmother was at the house
she ran it like the [ __ ] hat like a
whorehouse I mean she so i disrespected
her Richard and I've been doing coke all
night and Richard said she started
calling on the phone some was coming up
she says tell her we're not we can't
take the call and she thought that was
disrespectful and she sent this woman in
with a 2x4 smashed over my ladies [ __ ]
gonna top me started strangling me and
Richard finally like saw oh I think
she's killing her and she threw through
get this woman off me and I had some
[ __ ] to say at the grandmother but
Richard made me leave the house he said
you have you have to apologize to the
grandmother so she was someone to be
reckoned with I understood her though
you know I really did I you know growing
up like I mean living in that look what
she had to do to survive did help to
support everybody - but she was um when
she died Richard really Richard started
to come apart because it was his own
school it was his it was the only
nurturer he had you know really how was
his relationship his mind very tortured
you know she would she abandoned him she
was alcoholic she would come and go
but then of course he had to choose
between the grandmother and the mother
and they put him on in court on the
witness stand and he had to choose and
he had to choose the grandmother you
betcha
and he did but you know it was that was
a pain that he never got over I mean how
can you get over that right and the
father was a real taskmaster right and
of course he does routines about his dad
and how tough he was
buck-buck was a pimp in the whorehouse
yeah buck and yeah he's he used to say
to me I'm so glad you didn't meet buck
he would he would [ __ ] you in a minute
I'm like Richard your father he does oh
yeah oh yeah the second time you went
back with him how when we were together
till the yeah oh yeah oh yeah when I
came back in 94 I drove across country
with my two dogs and all my [ __ ] and
everybody was else I told you just
taking advantage and live in 20 minutes
down the freeway and they were all
cussing me out I said well you're 20
minutes on the freeway where were you
where the [ __ ] are you so I drove across
country and I you know that was the
summer 94 I pulled into his driveway and
rented a house right near him and I made
him sign up employment contract cuz I
did you never knew with Richard you know
sometimes he would just upset the
applecart because he could so I'm like
listen if I'm giving up my
rent-stabilized department I'm Beekman
place [ __ ] I am you better give
me you know some security here and it
took years just to get things in order
and we bought him a house and I told you
I closed the bank of Pryor so you know
we could organize it and then we had to
take care of him physically
so it was rehabilitating him financially
physically and and we did the box sets
and when I wouldn't have to drove it and
won that lawsuit chased him so I started
to organize everything and as I told you
the people who were smarter than me
should have been doing it and we're not
just gone oh no they were they were they
were taking what wasn't nailed down you
know for the last hour we've spoken
about Richard and I don't like second
usually I don't like second party
whatever but there was one other special
person in this relay
should lose you you're very very special
Jennifer thank you so much you're very
very special because they don't make one
like you no more women see heat now and
there's a divorce box a little
controversy and there's a de Bourgh oh
you called me a contact in you have to
look farther than that and you had the
wisdom that you've seen past the
comeback and the money and the coke and
the limos oh the party was over when I
came back Oh was it oh well in that
sense I mean you know it wasn't it
wasn't rock and roll anymore was it it
was it was hard work now it was like
let's clean up
let's coalesce the legacy let's do the
hard work now Richard you know you're
sick you're you know that's when that's
what real love is isn't it
I mean that's when the [ __ ] hits the fan
rubber meets the road man that's when
you find out who the [ __ ] you are and
who the [ __ ] you love you know inside my
wedding band I had initial to the wheels
fall off yeah that's me and my wife's
favorite say that's what become a Bob
Dylan song yeah yeah the wheels fall off
yeah and I look at you and I see why I
love my wife as much as I do
because like I said women come and go in
this [ __ ] lives they come up with
money they come with this you know how
hard it is to be economics wife because
at first you see the comedian on stage
you don't see the guy that that's right
it's booty that's right it doesn't wakes
up in a bad mood boy that doesn't want
to talk at night that doesn't like
politics right watch this close a
certain way one of the socks it [ __ ]
certain way you know I got home
yesterday my wife had the clothes is
washed but it wasn't put away but for a
minute I said something to it I go who
the [ __ ] by yeah to say something
yeah he's [ __ ] fight with a
six-year-old girl look at that but I
wanted to bring you world because I
don't think nobody's had a better fit
for you nobody's ever given you the
credit that you deserve for take it he
would have been dead listen when he came
out of the hospital near 80 that time oh
you know to explain the people that
don't know what cocaine was in 1980 yeah
you know we've just seen this marijuana
revolution exactly what day was a shoe
store now it's a pot store not
to pot stores the block yeah we saw
cocaine did unbelievable to a society
yes this it was like a case of the
[ __ ] measles you know I said that the
plague killed how many people may yeah
yeah the great plague cocaine was a
great plague and people like Richard you
know the first time I tried coke was
October of 79 something I was totally
against something I was totally against
then one day I went to the basement and
I went looking for something I saw a
bale and then one of the Bell and
somebody had left something somewhere
mom could watch and I took a rock out
and put it a little little fall and I
put it in my desk I didn't say nothin to
nobody for a month
hmm one day I played hooky with some
friends I said let me bring the coke
with me and we ended up doing it and
sprinkling in peppermint schnapps and
vodka Oh call them snow cones
oh we were drinking it and snorting it
and till this day I'm still friends with
the guy but not to take that off one
minute people were smoking pot and doing
acid yeah and the next minute everybody
was doing coke everybody was yeah I
can't imagine ya being Richard Pryor and
people putting it in your hand oh yeah
people just put in your hand your pride
they were bringing it in the hospital
when he was recovering from the fire and
he was doing it oh yeah in the hospital
yeah that's real but he did get sober he
did here and now sober do you yeah he
did he did so he got out of the hospital
June 1998 he was the fire he got out in
about six weeks and he had a handler
come and stay with him a male nurse to
kind of watch him and you know but he
was like this with the [ __ ] right and
and we got back together that Christmas
we went to Hawaii together and then the
following summer we got married and he
was he was sober then he actually smoked
some weed and in Hana but how
swarming we have we had built a house
down there and he goes he saw he got
paranoid and I kind of talked him off
the ledge and he said you know you're so
good to me you're just always good to me
will you marry me and I'm like oh I
don't know is I was kind of dating
somebody you know I was trying to trying
to get my feet back on the ground you
know and and I said all right okay we
married a week later of course he came
back too soon though he came back and
started doing that dope and robbing and
he started running together and partying
and he was which heading for the live on
Sunset and we moved into Trousdale
rented a house there so he was close to
the store but he started you know doing
doing the coke again and you know
marriage got rocky ended but he he he
got sober eventually and then did here
and now sober but it was always rocky
with him you know it was just always
back and I was like it would never be so
yeah it's just well you know you drink a
little
no no drinking smokey smoke edibles okay
take a xanax you got a vicodin poppy no
somebody gave me a Pittsburgh this
weekend somebody gave me a bag of weed
great guy VIN and went back to the hotel
there was two Kohana pins
oh wow yard P DS Wells Ben I looked them
up and their muscle relaxants but they
got Kathleen oh man you know my drug was
quaaludes man of course Bill Cosby had
all the quaaludes didn't see about that
714 man I tell them I even tell my
shrink you didn't do a quaalude that was
that [ __ ] was the bomb I got one saved
at the house do you little would buy it
from you I took I think I gave me three
like took it one day by myself I hear
you can still get him I don't know
no James no no there that's a that's a
heavy-duty oh yeah he died cleaned it
oh yeah oh
yes oh god Joe yeah you know he does
listen I was so proud of the care that
we took him he had a feeding tube
usually you have a feeding tube for one
year and they die from it six years he
had it and that's how well we took care
of him because that damn feeding tube
you have to clean it you have to change
it you have to I mean it is a thing he
was on dialysis the last year of his
life that's really you know he died of
heart failure but the kidneys were shot
the kidneys with what did it ya know I
thought he was done already when I saw
him he was yeah but he wanted to go bad
he was a wheelchair it was his
wheelchair and he wanted in 96 he was
doing not 95 96 he was responsible I was
living in Seattle and coming down and I
would never even go to the store like
fries that way I'm gonna go down there
oh I wish he did I could I filmed it I
we've got it on film and some of it is
is good but you know again I'm repeating
myself now but it was heroic and tragic
at the same time both it was both brave
of him to want to do that and also
tragic because he's not the predator
stalking the stage anymore that great
powerful you know wonderful energy that
he had in spirit so you saw him
compromised obviously very compromised
with this with the illness but the fact
that he still wanted to do it said so
much to me about what kind of man
Richard was and he still was funny I
mean he got a lot of funny [ __ ] in there
too it wasn't just you know sitting up
there but he hep it would hold this
martini glass and he would I don't know
how he never spilled it it was just it
was it was an art holding up glass with
the martini full to the brim not and a
cigarette in one hand you know and doing
his thing it was beautiful I know it
makes you sad to think
but on one hand you know it was a thing
of beauty that he's that's where he
wanted to be no I'm not sad about its
balls people added to the Richard Pryor
balls people would say to me how can you
let him do that
I said whoa get it straight here I'm not
letting him do or not letting him do
Richard wants to do this period we're
doing it instead of hiding in a closet
somewhere come on we're supposed to hide
he wanted to go out all the time he'd go
to the movies he'd go to you know we go
out to dinner we'd go to places we go to
events you know we always went to the
slaughter stuff the Comedy Awards you
know always going out there you know
always had a funny story about Richard
heard that towards the end he went up to
the store one night in a wheelchair and
there was a funny black comic up to the
store at the time he called them over
and the guy thought like you know I'm
the next Richard Richard looked at him
said get close and Richard when the guy
got down he goes stop doing my [ __ ]
that's interesting not gonna mention
donated even at the end yeah he told the
kid the Carver came over like yeah yeah
Richard what's up yeah like what's that
dog doing boy yeah
good I'm glad I'm glad I just heard a
Robin story that was interesting
Howie Mandel told the director this they
didn't make it in the documentary I wish
it had he said that he went to the store
one night and he saw Richard doing this
routine God comes to visit and asks
Richard if he can speak to Robert
Kennedy sorry
god he was killed well Jack the brother
oh no well he was killed too well Martin
Luther King
oh sorry God Malcolm X no I'm sorry you
could hear a pin drop
that's what Richards genius was too he
didn't always have to be funny and
that's somebody to remember to his
comics you don't always [ __ ] have to
be funny
hannah gatsby the new new girl that new
girl comic female comment yes yes yes
yes she's she's breaking some molds too
that I think are very interesting same
kind of thing you don't you don't always
have to be funny but so how he runs into
Richard on a plane
he says Richard that routine where God's
asking you to speak to all these dead
people
why'd you stop doing that that way you
you had everybody mesmerized he said cuz
Robin started doing it so true story
it's true story it's a true story
yeah Jennifer you always got a home here
thank you
I've enjoyed it I've enjoyed I enjoyed
you listen you made me go through a
rollercoaster of emotion good I was like
I said they're just some people that I
never wanted to really meet because I
loved them so much I would fall apart
you know when I saw Richard I fell apart
when Muhammad Ali's daughter said
Muhammad was on his way the economy so I
got my car and I hope he'll the [ __ ] out
of that does that him not wanna but
Richards one of those people that if it
wasn't for Richard I wouldn't be in this
office well I could say you got some of
his DNA you can say that yeah I
appreciate that in your appreciate you
real quick if you want to watch the new
doctor documentary I am Richard Pryor
visit I am Richard Pryor calm well you
can state stream or download it
visit Richard Pryor calm for news the
news official merchandise and to listen
to his classic albums also visit priors
planet.com if you'd like to donate to
help save lives provide sanctuary and
make a world better place for Hannibal
seem as an animal guy oh yeah no sure
yeah I mean II was glad I didn't have
kids he said we have dogs that's good
and visit Rock and pence calm for your
official Richard Pryor pizzelle sadly
paid Joey Diaz baby that's right
everybody pins up there
jennife I don't know what to say to you
I love you all oh yeah I love you too I
appreciate you having me very much and
like I said if you have a just board and
you want to talk some Richard stuff
alright I love to talk alright yeah me
too I love all this [ __ ] cuz I know you
have 10 more hours
Oh two hours that you don't even
remember I gotta give you a couple
martinis thank you very much
all right I want to thank Jennifer Brian
I want to thank [ __ ] the
[ __ ]
I want to thank Mauricio for coming out
from rocking pins but most importantly I
want to thank you guys for having our
back every [ __ ] week don't forget
Fridays all I got left to the rest of
the year for right now is April 4/20 the
second show Milwaukie I'll let you guys
know what's going on next week but for
right now all I got is 4/20 the second
Sean Milwaukee we got some dates in June
June 8th the 9th Dallas and San Antonio
got rescheduled we also got Columbus at
the end of June we got nothing in May so
far
cuz I'll be in New York shooting the
movie the next two months I'll be back
and forth Ellie will be running things
but don't worry about nothing I got your
[ __ ] beside that I want to
thank our sponsors let me ask you guys
your questions have you ever looked at
the phone of yourself and five years ago
some [ __ ] some things get better with
age
wine for example a nice single malt
scotch unfortunately this is not the
case when it comes to your skin and
especially your face I mean I'm no uh
jacking rabbit myself you know I'm
saying most guys don't build nearly do
enough for their skin despite all it
does for them soap and water are just
not enough to prevent aging but there is
something you could do in the fight
against aging and it's staring you right
in the face you ready for this
for hims calm a one-stop shop for skin
care hair loss and sexual wellness for
men hims anti-aging kits a custom
prescription cream tailored to your skin
to keep your skin looking beautiful
beautiful and youthful smooth by
reducing the appearance of wrinkles and
fine lines listen the secrets not a
secret it stretches
trechie neon and the results are backed
by science it can renew and restore skin
by increasing collagen the protein that
keeps your skin firm it takes seconds to
apply that's the same treatment
celebrities used to help keep their
faces looking young now hims connects
you with doctors online who will
evaluate your skin needs and can
prescribe you a custom anti-aging tree
all you need to do is take a couple
pictures answer some questions no more
awkward in-person doctor visits no
product these products are shipped
directly to your door now it's your skin
do you want to be an a face in the crowd
or just to face the crowd order now and
save $20 off your first month of hims
anti-aging kit lock in those looks now
and get your first month of anti-aging
for $20 off see website for full details
and safety information go to for hints
calm slash Joey SC that's for him calm
slash Joey SC again that's for him Skaar
slash
Joey SC let me explain something
summertime is coming you gotta be going
to parties and your balls are gonna
stink because you're [ __ ] sweating
that don't I need to happen alright
there's a thing called there's a company
called manscape comm and they got the
answers to your [ __ ] they got the
answer to your problems don't cut your
dick off [ __ ] all the suffering ends
today you don't know how many times my
wife's been trimming my [ __ ] nutsack
around my [ __ ] party Pole and the
next thing you know I'm [ __ ] sweating
bullets and I'm red those days are over
with manscape can get it done without
the pain the anxiety the frustration
they got precision tools for the Family
Jewels manscaped has redesigned the
electric razor their invention you ready
for this one the lawnmower is a handheld
razor with skin-safe technology so it
won't Nick or snag your sack or your
[ __ ] party Pole listen you got to go
easy on what the Lord gave you you know
I'm saying this bad boy will leave your
clean smooth and pain-free and no
anxiety plus it's rechargeable and easy
to hold get into all those nooks and
crannies by your [ __ ] your nutsack
underneath and the stings on that's the
that's a little piece of skin between
your nutsack and you ass all you got
that skin tone
it smells like ten dead [ __ ] bodies
you don't need that no more manscaped is
there to help you and I'm gonna let you
in on a little secret
if you trim the hedges the tree look
[ __ ] taller what are you waiting for
trim up that [ __ ] eggroll it's the
first time you've considered manscaping
they got a deal for you the perfect
package comes with a lawn mower and a
safety razor plus
the crop preserver especially the
formulated deodorant so your balls don't
stay and they have the Reviver a soup
rinse that tones and refreshes your junk
to keep it nice and cool listen manscape
got you covered when it comes to your
[ __ ] dick to your nut sex they even
got a ball wipe you understand me that's
how good [ __ ] man's game is so do me
a favor listeners the church family can
get 20% off your first order when you
use code Church CH you are CH at
manscape time and if you order the
perfect package forget about it they'll
throw in a free travel bag for you when
you use the code church and that bag
covers everything you got everything in
there you got your your [ __ ] your crop
preserving your revive I mean listen you
could put everything you'll be prepared
if you travel you nut so still be [ __ ]
as clean as if you were home I'll do me
a favor
if you order the perfect package let
throwing that free travel bag when you
use code Church that's manscape time use
promo code church for 20% off your first
order and do me a favor
this is how you keep your balls clean I
want to thank manscape don't want to
thank hims I want to take all you
[ __ ] are most important I want
to thank the listeners for keeping us
here and for letting us [ __ ] spread
our word every week don't forget for
22nd show in Milwaukee at the Pabst
Theater and that's it we're [ __ ] done
here have a great [ __ ] rest of the
week we'll be back on Thursday and
that's it and that's that Lee kick this
[ __ ] meal